if a woman in Hungary has four or more
children she is exempt from taxation
until the age of retirement so she pays
no income tax whatsoever and there's
like a 15% flat tax in Hungary what did
that do to their birth rate it increased
it from the late 1990s throughout the
2010s the total fertility rate was 1.3
so it remained stagnant and flat orbon
comes into power in 2010 or 2011 fidz
wins and these policies were implemented
in uh 2015 in 2010 when orbon was in
power the fertility rate in Hungary is
1.3 now in 2023 the fertility rate is
1.54 it hasn't had a massive increase
but it's had had an increase so we had
20 years of stagnation and all of a
sudden these policies are implemented
and you see a growth in the fertility
rate there is evidence that this stuff
works